ههه
ما عدا الملياردير الامريكي الى الماس
كوميديا كما ظنه بعض المستخدمين فخلفت تلك
الضحكات وجه صرم ينفذ سياساته المرجوه بلا
ان يتوانى قيد انمل عن تحقيق الهدف
قبل ايام اي منذ استحواذه رسميا على
العصفور الازرق غرد قائلا الكوميديا على
تويتر اصبحت قانونيه منشور لقى اعجابا من
قبل كثيرين على خلاف مساله توفيق الحسابات
ووضع العلامه الزرقاء مقابل الثمانيه
دولارات لانها لم تنى الاستحسان الاغلبيه
وامام ذاك القرار شهد تويتر موجه من
الانتقادات والدعابات كان يحاول مشاهير او
شخصيه معروف اسم العرض الى الى الماسك لكن
ماسك كان لهم بالمرصاد وانها امرهم بحضن
الحساب تماما كما جرى مع الممثله
الكوميديه كافي جريفن التي يتابعها نحو
مليون شخص غيرت اسمها والصوره الشخصيه
ليظهر الحساب خارجيا وكانه لماسك لكن رد
مالك العصفور الازرق لم يلبث الا قليلا
حتى اغلق حسابها
وكعادته يوم ماسك سياسته عبر سيل تغريدات
بداها قائلا ان المنصه لن تتهاون في تعليق
اي حساب عند انتحاله هويه بلا ان يحدد
صاحب الحساب انها مجرد محاكاه ساخره
وتابع ان التحقيقات ستاخذ مجراها وتتسع بل
انه لن يكون هناك تحذير واردف ان اي تغيير
في الجسم سيفقد الحساب مؤقتا علامته
الزرقاء حتى تعود المنصه التحقق منها
واضمن سياسه تويتر لا يجوز انتحال شخصيه
افراد او مجموعات او مؤسسات لتظليل
الاخرين او اربياكهم او حتى خداعهم لكن
المستخدمين يبدو انه معترضوا على مسالتي
الدولارات والمحاكاه الساخره فالاولى لا
داعي لدفعها اما الثانيه فتدخل بالنسبه
اليهم حيز حريه التعبير
اسراء الصغير العربيه